hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome back to
another high definition video tutorial
today we're going to be showing you guys
how to create and manage your own
youtube group in the new youtube layout
as of may 2010 now i say that because
the new youtube layout has been changing
quite a lot uh pretty recently so this
is what you're going to be able to do to
create your own youtube group i've
gotten this question a lot so first of
all go ahead and visit your channel like
i'm doing now
and actually what you're going to want
to do is visit any channel that has a
youtube group on it this is actually
something that i discovered as i was
looking around i went through like the
account settings i went through
different videos and different ways to
find a way to make a group but i
couldn't really find it it was difficult
to find so my old video about creating
youtube groups is actually no longer
valid so what i actually did was went to
the mkbhd group that's here on my
channel that i already created quite a
while ago that has a lot of videos
submitted by you guys etc and i just
went around here and looked for ways to
create a group but i still didn't find
one then at the top here at the top here
at this url bar i just went to this url
bar and i saw that this is the url of
the group and i figured
what would happen if i just remove the
end of the name and just go to
youtube.com slash a group and i hit
enter and sure enough we can see all
groups and we can show my groups or show
my new groups and create a group
so there's that magical i guess create a
group button that people have been
looking to find and i really haven't
been able to find
so there's the create a group button all
the same things the group name tag and
description and customize url are all
still here so what you guys are going to
do is create the group the way you
typically would hit the create group
button and you're good to go so just
remember that if you want to directly go
to create a group go to youtube.com
groups underscore create
and if you'd like to go ahead and view
all groups just go to youtube dot com
slash group i'm sorry slash groups
and there you go there's all the youtube
groups that have been recently created
so go ahead and check that out if you
still need more information about
anything regarding youtube groups or my
group itself feel free to contact me by
either leaving a comment or dropping me
a message and i'll definitely get back
to you as quickly as possible either way
this has been mkbhd and thank you for
watching this quick video and i'll talk
to you guys in the next one peace